the chairman's script
as chair of division two of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to
hb2 areas please note
that there is no fiscal location for
members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this
mission meeting however in accordance
with emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should email
lba underscore fiscal
at leg dot state dot nh
dot u s in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
the lba staff is are on the meeting
assisting us please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call let's start
the meeting taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required
under the right to know law so
representative lynn if you would call
the role
yes uh thank you madam chair uh uh
representative porter yes i'm here in my
home in hillsborough
and my husband is in the house but not
in the room with me
thank you uh representative turcotte
representative turcotte i'm in the
office of the
i don't know what it's called in the
state house anyway i'm here by myself
thank you representative heath good
morning
to the ides of march um yeah i'm your
heath and i'm
here in my home in manchester and my
husband is in the other room
thank you i'm representative lynn i'm
president of my home in windham
and my wife is in the house but not in
the room
uh representative murray good morning
kate murray's here in newcastle with my
dog
husband's in the basement thank you
just give me one second representative
petry
president teacher he's here in
farmington the dog and the
wife is roman halls again
thank you and representative umberger
yes i'm in my home in uh kearsarge my
husband is in the house
but not in the room thank you
all right thank you representative lynn
i'm
welcome to everybody again uh today
we're going to be talking about the
government scholarship program and
uh i am not sure
who wants to go first uh
the is it the treasurer or s
somebody else
hi madam chair uh i'm happy to kick
things off
uh today if if you would like but i'm
also joined
as you can see by uh treasurer misapelli
james q austin bfa
and i believe chris elms from our office
is on i don't know
mickey if you would be able to promote
him to a panelist
if you see him
okay uh matt that would be great if
you'd like to start out
excellent thank you madam chair and
members of the committee it's great to
be back in front of all of you again
this time to present
the governor's student debt relief plan
this is something of course that was uh
it has a lot of history to it if you
will
something that was proposed during the
last budget cycle
and it was then ultimately didn't make
it into the final compromise budget but
there was additional action
that took place last year trying to
build towards a consensus
and what i would say and what you see in
this proposal here today
really is a continuing a continuance of
that
compromise that was worked on last
session
and what we've done essentially is find
ways to
continue to invest these monies in new
hampshire students
and its workforce to make sure that
we're driving the best
outcomes for our state you notice
here in hb2 and it begins on page 68
for those of you that are following
along on the text
essentially as an opportunity to
reallocate
how these monies are distributed we've
put forward a plan where
20 percent will continue to go to direct
scholarships
the way it currently operates under
statute but then we took a hard look at
where the remaining 80 percent can best
be invested
and with that 20 percent would continue
to go to the unique endowment program
and the balance that remaining 60
percent
as a historic investment in student debt
relief
and workforce development
we see this as an opportunity to drive
students to stay in new hampshire to
work in new hampshire
especially in critical fields you notice
things that are called out specifically
nurses at state facilities or any
licensed medical professional
in addition to transformative things
like
biotechnology opportunities to continue
to grow our state
and make sure that we have the workforce
to really drive
forward those key initiatives that new
hampshire
is continuing to be a leader in
nationwide
again we see this as an opportunity
where
our workforce especially what we've seen
with coven 19
and the challenges the pandemic we
wanted to identify some of these key
fields and use this as a program for
good
right to make sure that we are able to
be nimble and respond to some of those
challenges as they arise
and as people you know are coming out of
the pandemic and looking at where they
may want to live
we know that new hampshire has seen a
hot real estate market
and especially people that might want to
find themselves in a more rural
environment
give this extra incentive for recent
graduates to
come live and work in new hampshire and
that that's the high level overview if
you will
again seeing this as an opportunity to
build on that success
um and i'm happy to take any questions
or you know if
james or monica want to you know touch
on some of those other aspects of why
we see this really as a tremendous
workforce driver
um and again just just celebrating the
success of the 529 plans
um and the other thing just to close uh
my section here is
none of this money is taxpayer dollars
right this all comes from assessment
revenue
from the 529 plan so finding a way to do
this
in a way that doesn't impact the general
fund is another key highlight of this uh
this real innovation and how we're able
to offer this type of assistance to
both students and recent graduates
uh chris did you have something you
wanted to add
i summed it up uh well for us but i'd be
happy to help answer any of these
questions
are there any questions from the
committee
at this point representative heath
thank you madam chair um i'm a little
bit confused
about how um i'm looking on page seven
as you begin to describe the the debt um
program and i just am um
unclear on really how it's going to work
and when it's up and running what would
it look like
so and this might be something where
james you feel free to chime in as
is your agency would be the
administrator of these funds
but this program is designed to be
nimble and flexible
you'll notice there's language in there
that not only delineates some initial
key workforce areas to start out
but also invest power with the
commissioner of the department of
business and economic affairs
through consulting with the commission
to identify additional
high priority fields that we might want
to extend these benefits to
but as far as how this would work the
bfa would be
um tasked with essentially offsetting
those loans of students that are
eligible for this program
i'm sorry recent graduates who are new
hampshire residents that are working in
new hampshire
and again to provide that existing
incentive a new
incentive to that existing workforce to
make sure that the high cost of student
debt
is not a barrier for them to continue to
work in new hampshire
and provide these these critical
benefits but james i'm happy to turn it
over to you
if there's anything else you'd like to
add on that
good morning everybody for the record
james key wallace executive
director from the ufa um you know i
should i'm sure like the treasurer will
always begin with a caveat that we can't
take uh positions for or against the
legislation
although of course we certainly
acknowledge the you know impact this
would have on our ability to recruit
workforce
in these key areas so you know i uh
i could take the committee through the
mechanics of
how a student loan forgiveness program
is proposed to work
if that's something the committee uh
would like it would just take
a few minutes would that be helpful
so this excuse me i think that would be
helpful
to let us all try to understand this
great thank you madam chair so this
legislation it really is a springboard
off of what was existing legislation
you know some of you may remember from a
few years ago
to provide student loan forgiveness as a
workforce attraction tool
for the regenerative medicine industry
you know that program was always
designed to be scaled up to apply to
other industries as
needed and a lot of the same
underpinnings you know exist here in
this bill
so but to speak to the legislation
directly
the legislation authorizes the bfa to
design
a program that meets certain key
standards
it defines what the industries are for
eligible participants
while also acknowledging that that
should be a living list
as needs change throughout the future it
also says
basic things like they need to have a
degree certificate of some kind from an
accredited institution
and then it says bfa please design the
program
and before you launch it the program we
designed would have to be brought to
the fiscal committee which is the same
way it was done
with the regenerative medicine student
loan forgiveness program
so that work had been done in prior
years the fiscal committee
during the last session was very
enthusiastic about the program design
so i would imagine this would work in
essentially the same way and it's as
follows so how it works
is for an individual to be
eligible the first thing that has to
happen is their
employer has to register so their
employer has to be certified by us
that they are of the type that's allowed
under the legislation
right you know direct care health care
providers
you know employees at the state hospital
you know there's biotechnology
you know things like that so we say yep
you're a valid employer
therefore your employees are now
eligible
and the kind of boundaries on the
program are that
80 of the money needs to go to folks who
got their degree
within the last two years right so it's
we want to attract
new workforce into the state you know or
retain new graduates that are you know
here and we want them to stay
the other piece of the legislation says
that we need to
whatever degree feasible try and ensure
that people from
low and moderate income you know people
who have financial need
are the ones targeted in the program to
try
and get the money to where it's going to
have the most impact
so then after that if an individual is
accepted into the program
they will sign a five-year commitment
say i'm going to stay in new hampshire
for five years
they sign up we work with them we
identify
all of their outstanding qualified
student loans let's say it's twenty
thousand dollars
at the end of the first year assuming
the person has continued to work there
they continue to make their student loan
payments to their student loan providers
we say all right how much do you owe you
finish your first year
so out of these funds we will cut a
check to pay down a
percentage of your current student loans
so it gets knocked down by a child
year two goes by they keep making their
student loan payments at the end of year
two
we do the same thing year three same
thing so each year
that loan gets knocked down and knocked
down to the point where
by year five your student loan is now
eliminated
it actually you have a little bit of a
hidden benefit in this system
because since they're continuing to make
their payments
we pay down their principal their own
payments now less of it gets consumed by
interest to the student loan companies
and it goes more toward principal
so people actually pay off their own
loans faster
under the system and those advances that
we make
are technically loans to that individual
at zero percent no payments due no
interest is accruing it's technically a
loan
we are making at the end of each year
that at the end of the fifth year
if they complete the program that loan
is forgiven
and they're done if for some reason
somebody moves away
and decides you know incorrectly that
wyoming's a better place to be
they actually owe that money back to the
trust
and they have to pay it back on the same
terms as whatever they were paying their
student loan
that way the person's and so that's
the job so we would be in the role of
verifying employers employees
managing what would probably be you know
several hundred
counts per year enrolled into the
program
resolving any issues with the customers
and trying to help people out
thank you uh mary did that answer your
question
um yes madam chair i just could inquire
a little bit further
um to um to matt if possible please
yes you may matt um i believe
we had quite a conversation about this
program
in the last session but my big concern
is
that um in the past millions of dollars
have gone well
number one we we failed to provide any
funding for the scholarship
the running staff program and and um
just it would really cause a hardship on
so many families
but secondly i think this is a a
a great idea but what about all the
students we have in the state of new
hampshire going to four-year
institutions or two-year institutions
who have depended on the the funds
that have been in the unique program um
and the universities
um across our state that depend on those
funds
um those dollars will not get there
so what does that mean for those
institutions
especially at um this remarkably
difficult period in time for higher ed
well representative heath what i would
say to that is ultimately this program
continues to make
investments in those same endowments
which have done
tremendously well over the life of this
program right we haven't
we've seen those endowments be built up
continue to grow
and we continue to make investments
there and just looking back to
what the compromise legislation was
introduced
in 2020 that would have allocated
say two million dollars to those
endowments this proposal remains
more generous than what was introduced
last session
right so we aren't trying to vilify the
endowments by any way
but what we are trying to do is show
that we've
met a certain threshold where we can
continue paying scholarships
to students out of those endowments well
also address
other emergent needs with workforce by
providing the student debt relief
so i think that ultimately we struck the
appropriate balance
to continue making investments continue
to pay out scholarships
from those endowments in addition to the
20 percent
that goes to direct scholarships doesn't
also give students this glide path that
if you
stay in new hampshire for five years and
we know that people that decide to live
in a location
for five years they become a part of
that community and they're more likely
to stay
and that has benefits to new hampshire
that go far beyond just the student debt
relief program
but again striking that balance allowing
those endowments to
continue to grow as a result
and ultimately again create that
flexibility for the state
to use these dollars which are a
testament to success
of 529 plans and make sure those dollars
go to the areas of the greatest need
thank you very much representative
porter you had a question
i do madam chair thank you i actually
have two questions and again these are
newbie questions
um and i don't know who will answer them
so it sounds to me like money is being
taken out of the scholarship program
and put into this loan forgiveness
program am i
reading hearing it wrong that's my first
question
and my and my second question is is
there an
upper limit for the loans that are
forgiven
if a student has a hundred thousand
dollars
worth of loans is a hundred thousand
dollars gone at the end of the five
years
or is it only maybe ten thousand dollars
of their hundred thousand dollars
thank you matt if you would answer that
please
yes thank you representative porter and
i'll kick the second one over to james
but what i would say is that no money is
being taken out of direct scholarships
the current provision is 20
of the unique program funds that remains
at 20
what we're doing is adjusting what
percent goes to the university
endowments
which do pay a small fraction of that
money in scholarships
but also now investing that in student
debt relief
um for individuals that live in new
hampshire and are working in new
hampshire
uh and james do you have the specifics
offhand
i think this might be something that
ultimately has established the rules but
thank you representative reporter
there's no legislative cap
because the amount will probably vary by
industry the
proposed amount we had put the fiscal
committee in the regenerative medicine
iteration of this was 50 000 recognizing
that
student loan debt is a lot higher than
anyone's really realized
but also recognizing that you know you
can't have
a small number of enrollees eating up
too much of the fun
so 100 000 too much 50 000
felt like the ceiling um the average
will probably be much
less than that considering that this
program is equally open to folks
with two-year degrees as it is
that's the cat thank you thank you
representative lynn you had a question
yes uh thank you madam chair actually i
i i have a series of questions one of
which
representative porter i i the the answer
to her question i think
um answered although the question the
first question i have is
um i'm on the board the 529 board
and i i thought that very recently we
had re uh rearranged the allocation
between the endowment and the direct
scholarships so that it was
significantly more went to the direct
uh scholarships and less to the
endowment
am i and so i i think that
sort of when we when you said before
matt that it was 20 percent
um that went to direct scholarships i
thought that we had changed that
recently
uh mrs madison am i wrong on that
go ahead good morning thank you madam
chair uh thank you representative
um i think you know i think it was uh it
was um
really good time to provide a little
background i think
before i try to answer that question i
think it sounds like maybe some
legislators are not familiar with the
actual program so i think that's how we
can
um provide a little information
the there are two two types of
scholarships the
the direct scholarships what uh um
director melo is referring to the and
there's an endowment
program so funding goes to this
endowment program
and then in turn these endowments um
provide these
direct scholarships to um new hampshire
students
and that in the rules that stated that
is
80 should go to this endowment
and then um the rest which is about 20
goes to what we call the unique
annual allocation program and those are
direct scholarships that go
to students and and those are um
essentially the scholarships that um
[Music]
the adva the college tuition savings
advisory commission um determines the
eligibility criteria for that
so to answer your question um
representative lynn
last year in 2020 the commission voted
to change
the allocation or the percentage that
goes to the endowments versus the direct
scholarships
and and through that request or through
that decision that the commission made
we spoke to the governor the governor's
office and the governor issued
an executive order to change the um
to change the percentage on a temporary
basis so what that did is he changed the
rule
uh for a period of one year so 70
would go to direct scholarships during
the current academic year
and the rest to the endowment so that
was a temporary change
that allowed to it did two things it
really expanded the eligibility for
students
um because you raised the um
the one of the criteria the one of the
criteria was
to uh is the expected family
contribution
before it was zero so we were able to
increase that to one thousand
and also the um and also the award
amount changed from
800 to 1000 so with the ability to have
more fun than in the annual allocation
program
we were able to expand this scholarship
program and provide more scholarships
and more money to students during this
difficult time
so so so you're correct that that change
occurred but it will expire at the end
of this
fiscal year and at that point the rules
will
will go back to how they were
and then 80 will go to the endowments
and 20 will be for the um
for the direct scholarship program the
annual allocation program
right okay so but i guess what i so i
mean that i guess what i'm saying though
is
as compared to the way it is right now
that 70 goes to direct
to direct scholarship it would be
from that am i correct in understanding
that it would be from that
70 percent of money that goes to
direct scholarships right now that a
significant portion of that would would
be reallocated to
the debt forgiveness am i correct in
that
that is correct and so then the next the
next ques
i guess if i may madam chair i have yeah
excuse me just a moment
who is currently managing that uh direct
scholarship
program so the the advisor commission
oversees this program the program itself
lives
is housed in the treasury so treasury uh
makes all the disbursements and we
disperse all the funds to
all of the participating uh colleges and
universities
so it's the college and universities
that are actually running the direct
scholarship program
is that correct they are the ones that
decide
uh and through the financial aid
packaging they select
all eligible students and they're the
ones that disperse
and award the funds the scholarships we
we simply manage um we provide the
funding to them
and and they report back to us with a
number of scholarships that they
award every year okay thank you
representative lynn i'm sorry continuing
no no no no that's fine thank you that
was
an important clarification um i i i
guess the the other thing that i want to
make sure i'm understanding is
i i understand that you that that from
what you were saying
uh mr key wallace that there's no that
that this would be something that would
have to be decided by rules
uh but it's it sounds like if i'm
correct and please correct me if i'm
wrong
that the potential amount of money that
would be that could be
forgiven a per individual
would be substantially higher i mean
even if
let's say it's you limit it to 50 000
that would be substantially higher
than the maximum amount that students
under the current program can get in
loans for i mean if i understand
it correctly it's two thousand dollars a
two thousand dollar scholarship for four
years so eight thousand dollars
and so i i guess what i'm concerned
about candidly is
if you compare let's say eight thousand
dollars
under the current program to 50 000
under the under the loan forgiveness
program it that suggests that there will
be
considerably fewer people that will be
able to take advantage of the
loan forgiveness program than the then
the scholarship
program and i'm kind of to be honest i'm
really kind of concerned about
why that makes sense
thank you representative um you know the
that just has a
quick point of clarification uh although
uh
i think it may have been the time by
budget director mayu so it won't be
the rules process just to be clear
since it'll actually be through a
program endorsed by the fiscal committee
it won't be through a
jail care process but um the
amount you know it is certainly subject
to
the approval by that fiscal committee if
they wanted to
lower the ceiling to ensure more people
got it
i think they could however i think
you're you're right
in that you know unless they set it at
eight thousand dollars which i don't
think they will
and you couldn't run i think an
effective recruitment tool
at that level you need a bigger amount
i do think that it will be more
concentrated as opposed to spread out
and so the idea is you know concentrate
those
resources in the industries where the
workers are most acutely needed
the most effective in getting those
folks into the state
as opposed to sort of spreading it out
you know i mean
i think the real policy your
consideration for the
legislature here is do you want to
you know help make affordability on the
front end by providing small amounts
to more people to go to the institution
with no guarantee whether or not they'll
stay in new hampshire
or do you want to put bigger amounts
in the hands of still a lot of people
but a fewer number of people with an
absolute
guarantee that 100 of them will stay or
else they have to give them money
so i think that's really the policy
and thank you james i think you
articulated that perfectly right this is
a
highly targeted program to key
industries right where the existing
scholarships
aren't tied to specific fields in the
same way and
also don't come with that guarantee that
people that attend the new hampshire
school
won't go find a job in boston for
example or any other part of the country
because we know we can export graduates
our challenge has been finding
ways to create incentives for them to
stay and provide workforce especially in
rural areas of the state
so then again to james point how
targeted and how large of an incentive
is the policy consideration for sure um
but we see the merits of this
being that workforce driver with
guaranteed benefits to stay
here within the state may i ask just one
more question
of representative berger yes you may
thank you and and uh the last question i
have is
um is um is
when the under this proposed proposed
program when the loan is forgiven
is is that a taxable event or or is
there some exception in the
irs code that says you know this kind of
loan forgiveness is not
is not a taxable event
so i to my understanding that that is a
taxable event the same way that other
existing
federal programs uh whether it be the
public
uh service loan forgiveness program or
others
uh this would have similar tax
implications to those other existing
programs
and just to clarify one thing uh this
program would be
mutually exclusive of those so a student
or a recent graduate
uh couldn't participate in more than one
program
um so this would just be limited to this
single program but
uh to my knowledge would be taxable at
the end or actually would be taxable
james and this might be a question for
you but taxable at the end or
when each loan has been issued year to
year
yes thank you and representative it's
also my understanding it would be
taxable
um like many other kind of you know
programs like that but
it's taxable upon the event of
forgiveness because that's when the
participant would need to report that as
for forgiveness of debt income or debt
cancellation income
which would occur collusion of the five
year
period so they would you'll be very
clear up front this is what your
eventual tax
increase would be you know we of course
coach people along the way to be
prepared for that
one caveat i would put on that is that i
don't
i don't know this but i did read that
in the stimulus plan that the president
just signed
there were some alterations to the
taxability of certain student loan
forgiveness programs and i
don't know if that's only for federal
programs or if it's possible for
state-run programs but
it's certainly something we're looking
into sure
thank you very much representative
turcotte i believe you were next
thank you madam chair yeah i have a
couple quick ones if you don't mind
um the first one is you you uh somebody
was mentoring the five-year
commitment um
maybe it's i have an old copy of hb2 or
whatever but it
the one that i'm reading actually
eliminates that five-year commitment
somebody speak to that representative
turcotte which page are you
on it's page 71
second paragraph the dimension of the
five years is stricken
[Applause]
why don't you start james but what i
would say is we are amending an
existing statute that was specifically
tailored to regenerative manufacturing
so it might just
be a matter of that but james if you
have it
i believe that's right man but your
right representative
it is being proposed i see here to be
struck
in the statue the proposal
for how the program will operate for the
fiscal committee is going to
have a five-year commitment if you have
less than that
i don't really think you get the bang
for your buck for wiping out this debt
um if you ask for more than that i think
you
have a high likelihood that you know
it's just too long to kind of seal the
deal
can i continue madam chair with uh two
more quick ones
absolutely thank you um
the second one it's kind of a theme here
representative lynn
and i think it was representative porter
talking about the
the amount of the student debt so
it's it's really a couple part question
i guess combined
into one but let's say we have two
students with fifty thousand dollars
debt each um who
first point our first question who's
going to decide
how much of each of that fifty thousand
is forgiven who's going to be making
those decisions
uh matt we can't hear you your lips are
moving
but we can't hear you sorry about that
representative i was uh double muted
um this would be something that the
fiscal committee would ultimately
endorse
uh to the extent that demand for the
program outstrips the available funding
um there would be a determination made
at that point
but again that's assuming that both
individuals you know are qualified they
meet all the criteria
um and again that's something that if
there's legislative intent to
specifically insert
uh a provision of that nature um that's
something the legislature
could certainly uh do but again it would
be
on an equal playing field um depending
on the availability of the funds
go ahead with your follow-up or new
questions
well yeah uh you were i was kind of
missing i don't know if it's on my end
that the uh audio's not working or
everybody's saying it might be
the room i'm in uh but i miss part of it
um
but i can go back and look no problem uh
the last part
um is i i note that there's a
propensity throughout hb2 and a lot of
other things that keep mentioning
the biotech industry and and such is
there a particular reason why that's
happening throughout
so the existing statute and this comes
from the bill
that was passed i believe in 2018 that
specifically created a program for
advanced regenerative manufacturing
um these conversations that both started
with house bill 2 two years ago
and continued in 2020 have sought to
broaden that program um and and leverage
these 529 assessments
to provide that student gut relief not
only to biotechnology but also to other
key workforce areas such as nursing
or other things that are delineated both
in the statute
and then the commissioner of bea could
uh address additional uh
necessary areas for workforce
development so i would just attribute
that to
an outgrowth of where these
conversations started several years ago
and rather than coming at this from a
blank plate
again we're continuing to build on on
that initial proposal
thank you representative murray i
believe
no i'm sorry representative porter i
believe you were next
thank you madam chair um one of the
things that i've done
as part of my legislative duties is to
serve on the
new hampshire commission for deafness
and hearing loss and
um during that work i learned that
there's a critical
shortage of interpreters for the deaf
and that they
carry quite a lot debt load and in the
last budget we put a line into the
budget
to allow their debt to be part of a debt
forgiveness program i believe that's
what the
the budget did although no money was
allotted so my question
is who will be determining what
industries and programs
will be eligible for this kind of
loan forgiveness is it areas where we
have critical shortages like
interpreters for the deaf or is it
industries that we want to encourage to
grow in the state like
biotechnology
sorry about that this bill does
delineate specific
criteria including any licensed medical
professional
which would be captured in hb2 is
introduced
and then again the authority rests with
the commissioner of the department of
business and economic affairs
and this commission to identify other
areas down the road
that would be good fits for this type of
program
and the reason we've granted that
authority is for this program to remain
nimble
right right now we have a challenge
specifically
with healthcare workforce who's to we
aren't going to try to predict what the
needs of the state might be in five or
ten years
but given a program that has the
potential to be as successful as this
one
this can be a very effective tool to
address in real time
uh workforce development concerns that
might arise
uh in the future so we have an initial
list
it's a very uh healthcare focused list i
would say
um and then the commissioner of bea with
the advice
of the commission could expand that
should they see a need to do so
representative heath you have a question
yes thank you madam chair
um i remember well the industry that
this was specifically
geared toward um my question is
well first of all i just would like to
say i'm deeply
disturbed by the fact that hundreds of
new hampshire
students will not receive any kind of
support as they had previously
as well as our universities and colleges
will lose a large amount of scholarship
money that they have to give up but my
question to you
is specific to those businesses
that will benefit and it is an
extraordinary benefit
um will they be putting in
some funds to match these scholarships
or will this
just be a scholarship based on
those areas that are decided upon and
there's no contribution
on the part of the business if you could
reply please
well i guess what i would start off is
just to address some of your concerns in
the first part of that question
there is still money that will go to
university endowments
and that money will continue to provide
for scholarships
to students at new hampshire
institutions so just because we're
reallocating some of the funding
doesn't mean that the the
very well warranted assistance to
current students
that doesn't evaporate overnight right
we know that this program has
continued to build university endowments
tremendously over the past two decades
um and they're now at a spot where they
can continue to pay out scholarships
even if we're putting somewhat less
proportion of these uh 529 assessment
dollars
into those endowments
as for the second part of your question
and i apologize representative heath
what was the second part of that
question
will the businesses make any
contribution to the repayment
of the scholarships
thank you and i know when this bill was
first passed in 2018
there was some provision um for
the advanced regenerative manufacturing
to to put
forward um some sum of money i don't
know where that stands and i'm happy to
report back to the committee
and i guess james if there's anything
that you have to add that representative
heath's happy to respond to that
question
once i have a chance to check on that
for you
yes i represented people can have a
little bit
the there's nothing in the current
legislation that requires
a business to pay if their workers want
to take advantage of the program
right because this is really a program
to help new workers
come to the state um you know it's
really for that individual
there's nothing in the legislation that
says we need to get money from a
business to let their employees have a
benefit
however in the proposal from the bfa to
the fiscal committee we do
propose an administrative fee be paid by
the business when they first
sign up to have their employees all be
eligible this is going to help them
recruit workers right
it's actually going to be a very
powerful improvement tool
and there's some administrative costs
that the business should help
cover um in order to participate it's
not
particularly onerous because getting the
business
verified that they're the right kind is
not that difficult
but they at least need to cover the cost
but the real benefits for the employee
uh representative murray you have a
question yes i've got
um two short questions and one that's a
little longer the first one um
representative heath already addressed
but i just wanted to sort of iterate
that this is a benefit to the business
and it seems to me they should have some
skin in the game
um if it should be to their benefit to
keep their employees so i just wanted to
um piggyback on representative heath i
think that's
something that's um rather important to
consider
the second thing did i understand
correctly that the choices of this would
be made by
the fiscal committee when you say fiscal
you're saying fiscal committee
i i am um representative thank you
yes and i agree skin in the game is sort
of the motto at the bfa by the way on
your previous point but um
so yes the legislation requires that the
student the debt forgiveness workforce
improvement
plan before any action can be taken the
legislation requires that the plan which
will include
a lot of the details we're talking about
here today the limit on the amount
the employer contribution all of that
needs to be approved by the fiscal
committee
before operation furthermore the
program is subject to oversight by a
cross-section of legislative and other
of a commission that provides oversight
to the program
um representatives from the house and
the senate
labor others and then is tasked with
making annual
adjustments to the program if necessary
make sure that it's
performing with respect to a fiscal
committee you know and
all the hard work they do um my first
inclination is that i'm not sure that's
the best group to make these kinds of
decisions
and i shall have to think long and hard
about that but that to me
raises concerns about how they're going
to make their decisions
the third thing is a little bit longer
and this is
just basic information for me i'm just
kind of i've lost my road map here
um the first thing that confused me
you've changed the higher education
endowment to the higher education trust
fund
can you go over why
why the name change what does that mean
and can you just go over
when you're saying you know money is
going from here to here it's going to go
from endowment to scholarships to here
i've kind of lost
the thread of what's going where from
where
can you just give a um sort of a
schematic of what this looks like
sure representative murray and i would
say on the name change
you know really just just changing the
focus given that
you know currently the endowments are a
large share i think that that's part of
the reason why it
focuses on endowments um just given that
the the reallocation of those funds
um the name change is just you know for
consistency with that
i wouldn't read into it too far other
than just to say
um trying to align you know the name of
the program with how the program
operates
and then as far as where the money is
going are you talking the current
allocations
to what we're proposing or from the
actual entities that
that administer it both i think
where is the money that's going into
there and then how
um and currently i think it's
all you you tell me so
these dollars come to the state from 529
college savings plans that are
administered by fidelity
uh the state takes a share of an
administrative fee fidelity takes a
share of administrative fee
that program has been tremendously
successful over the past two decades
it's been a boon to the state and its
students
our intention is to continue that boon
and deploy these dollars in ways that
can continue to benefit
both current students and recent
graduates
right now 20 percent goes to direct
scholarships
that's paid um
out of an accounting unit at treasury
and with that we are not making any
changes to that 20
that goes to direct scholarships
currently 80 so that remainder
goes to university endowments
this proposal will shift that
to a 60
to student debt workforce development
and relief
and 20 would stay with those endowments
that's the the high level change um
the bfa would be tasked with
administering that student debt relief
program once it's up and running yes
representative murray go
back um and so in the university
endowment
right now 80 percent of the fidel
fidelity money goes to that
and you said right now um 60
goes nope so right now it's 20
to direct scholarships right 80 to the
endowments
okay excuse me excuse me
the treasurer said that that was changed
for this fiscal year
that 30 is going to endowments
and 70 is going to
direct scholarships so the 80
20 was old business so to speak
and that this new percentage runs out
at the end of june
and then it switches back to the
uh 80 20. so
yeah so that temporary change that was
made for this fiscal year
um i i guess i'm not accounting for that
in my comments
given that it's temporary right so the
the ongoing program
would be that 80 20 split as of july 1st
uh you know the new fiscal year um
so i i'm trying to stay simple at a you
know a higher level
um traditionally it has been maybe 20
split and
it would go back to that at the
conclusion of this fiscal year
you came out with 60 for students and
then 20
and then you went on to something else
so right now under current law absent
the temporary change that was made
80 20. this new proposal is
20 20 60.
20 to direct scholarships 20 percent to
endowments
60 to student debt relief
so if you wanted to do a crosswalk
between where we are and where this
language and hb2 would take us
the 20 for direct scholarships has not
changed
that endowment portion
20 of that stays the same and then we
introduced a new category
for student debt relief without
remaining sixty percent
another way of saying that is that the
university endowment goes down sixty
percent
yeah so again we're still providing
20 of the funds in that type of support
for
their endowments and to help students
with scholarships
through that program and again we're
trying to be more targeted in how we can
support
students after they graduate relieve
some of those
pressures that are tied to the high cost
of college
and provide them that debt relief
assuming they continue to stay in new
hampshire continue to work in new
hampshire
and do so for five years what does the
university do with this
uh do you have a follow-up yeah a
follow-up please
hopefully just one thank you so much
sorry what is the
what does the university endowment go
for
so those dollars are used to pay
additional scholarships to students
and they pay some percentage of that
each year
and again those scholarships i think
james d wallace and others have touched
on
are small and dispersed where
this new student debt relief program can
target specific industries
and provide a enhanced benefit if you
will
because of the enhanced benefits that
not only the state receives
uh but also the need to drive workforce
in critical sectors
thank you madam chair if i may just to
follow up on matt's
point yes please um so these endowments
are
the the small disbursements that they
give are designed to help
maintain sort of the uh self-sustaining
nature of these for
uh these um funds uh the endowments are
were built they're at a healthy
capitalization they're able to
continue to you know sustain themselves
through through interest and
investments uh while dispersing a small
amount
this isn't taking money away from those
existing endowments
it's simply reallocating some of the
money that would be used to help grow
those
uh those endowments because we feel and
we've
seen that they've reached a healthy uh
you know
uh balance where they're able to help uh
sustain themselves
a smaller amount maintain uh it does not
reduce
those those endowments and thank you for
that chris
uh you were going to uh somehow or other
gather up uh how large the endowments
were for
all of the colleges that get some of
this money
yes i believe we can put that together
um treasury i believe keeps data on that
but monica and i or
treasurer israeli and i will connect uh
offline and so we can report back on
whether it's aggregated totals or if we
can
provide a more detailed analysis
how many excuse me for interrupting here
but
how many colleges and universities do we
actually
support with this endowment
uh thank you madam chad i can i can
answer that we have um we have 10
colleges and universities
in and um i just would like to add right
now
um the total aggregate is about 137
million dollars so
they have over time um been able to grow
those endowments so it is
it is um it is it is true that they have
the ability to um
um to continue providing scholarships so
the endowment program
is all established in the rules um
that the um advisor commission has um
rulemaking authority to
to um to set those rules and and that's
how these two programs have been
operating
uh since 2006. so um i think one of the
clarifications i just want to i just
want to make is uh
a couple of things this um all this fun
then
comes um to what we call an endowment so
i think there's been a little
um confusion um how this works the um
the statue rsa 630a establishes
the um it is an endowment trust fund and
that's where
we keep all of um the the proceeds that
come from
um the fidelity of send us every month
so that's where all of this funding
lives
and um perhaps that's the reason why the
language and the status
shows the endowment i don't think it has
anything to do with the endowment
program so i just wanted to clarify that
um the second piece is um
today i'm you know sort of wearing two
hats i i serve on the advisory
commission i also
uh the treasury but um i'm trying to um
um as i think um
uh mr wall uh kewala said i i do not um
either i do not support or or be against
the legislation i just
my goal today is to provide as much
information as i can
if if there's a if there's a way to do
that but i know for example that the
advisor commissioner has a position on
this bill
and then they'll be able to um as a
point you know provide their
their views of how they see um the pros
and cons of this bill but
um so in terms of how the endowments
work
they are required to disperse
uh a minimum of four percent of their
balance every year
and what i can say is is that this
this particular program the endowment
program
unique endowment location program was
designed
to um to create scholarships in
perpetuity so um we we
fund this this this endowments every
year
sending 80 of these proceeds that come
from
the this administrative assessment and
then the the
the other funding goes to uh direct
scholarships
i know the commission has discussed over
the last couple of years
um they have discussed the possibility
of changing that allocation so
i just want to mention that their
ability to change the allocation lifts
and the rules
through the rulemaking authority and i
just wanted to just
this the differences um with this
proposal
the change will occur in the statute
rather than the rules so i just wanted
to
clarify that that all this time the
commission has had the ability to
to make those decisions and decide where
the funding should go
but with this proposal it will stay in
in the law it will be set
it will be codified in the law
again i just wanted to add those those
points of clarification
thank you so yes i think i'm not exactly
sure who
i've got a couple people that will be
speaking from uh
other that are listening in to uh
to to take care of this so uh
representative
lynn you have a question yes and i have
to i have to confess initially that out
that
about because of what i'm about to say
and that is because although i am a
member of the advi of the 529 advisory
commission
i had to leave the last meeting early
because i had to testify on some other
legislation and so
i don't know you um monica you mentioned
that the
the committee had taken the commission
had taken a uh i guess a vote or a
position on this and i don't frankly
know what that is
uh maybe maybe you could you could
educate us please uh i i
would like to say that i don't they'll
be happy to testify uh
if they have the ability to do that what
i know is that the commission decided um
during the last meeting on march 8th
and it was based on a discussion
representative weiler also serves on the
commission
and he won he was interested in
in proposing an amendment to the bill
that will allow
the commission to um not have
that set percentage set in the statute
it will
it will i think the amendment um if it
has been introduced
um will will give the advisor commission
the ability to change the percentage
relative to that 40 so the the
commission decided and voted on
supporting the idea that the that
instead of
2020 that will be split between the two
programs
that would be um at the discretion of
the commission
and and so i think the amendment was
going to uh read that the advisor
commission will have the ability to
um to set the percentage
according to how they wanted to manage
the program
um so that was one position that the
commission decided um
the other one is i think if if this
if this proposal um were not to pass
the commission would like to change
the percentage or the
rather than 80 20 they would like to
change it
70 30 um in the rules
and so if this doesn't go through the
commission will
will go ahead and vote and and change
their administrative rules
so the 70 goes to direct scholarships
and 30 percent will go
to the endowment program so that was the
decision that was made on march
thank you can i have a follow-up madam
chair
just a moment i think i sent everyone
representative wyler's comments if i
didn't i apologize
uh but the what the amendment current
you know what
something that will not decide today but
it reads
the commission will receive 40 of the
funds
which means 60 for endowment i guess
and will decide the split
between the direct scholarships to new
hampshire residents
attending new hampshire institutions of
higher education
and the unique endowment allocation
program
that's that's what he sent so um
uh yes mr key wallace
thank you madam chair i happen to have a
conversation with one of the members of
the commission and um
tell me if this is wrong but i think
what they that
amendment does is it does
keep the 60 in
as proposed for student debt relief so
they
would keep that in for student debt
relief then the remaining 40
would say the commission decides how
much is endowments
how much is it that way they can flex
the number
according to the current need i believe
that's the intent
of the commission's recommendation
monica please correct me if i'm wrong
but i think the amendment designed to
keep the student
forgiveness intact
and and that was the uh that is correct
that is the amendment that
representative while uh
wilder wasn't um had intention to to um
to introduce yes so
obviously i have
thank you so you know i guess um
one of the things that that really
concerns me and i
please understand i i think that this
idea of
debt forgiveness may to attract people
to new hampshire may well be
a good one um but i i am concerned about
the fact that
one of the main reasons that we changed
even though it was on a temporary
basis the allocation between the
endowment and the direct
loans was was just as i think
one of you pointed out that the
the endowments are now you know pretty
well established and
are at pretty good levels and we
uh the commission had received
information that
you know they weren't uh they were the
colleges and universities were tending
to just build up those endowments and
not really make
very many uh or at least not as many
scholarships available as we would do
through direct scholarships and because
the commission wanted to increase the
number of direct scholarships that was
the reason
we changed the allocation so
this is sort of you know this is
kind of going back on that if you will
and it may be for a good reason but the
thing that i'm i'm wondering
is would this make sense to instead of
us
acting upon it now to have
um you know a further study done on this
because
for example i don't i i i can see the
arguments on both sides of this and it
seems to me to be a kind of close
question
and one of the things that i would like
to know for example is
exactly how important are the
scholarships
to the students that are getting the
scholarships now
in other words if you know uh the
scholarships aren't
aren't all that big two thousand dollars
as i understand it per year at the most
um with the given the cost of a
four-year even at the university of new
hampshire
i'm not saying it's unimportant but it
but i'd like to know
what what percentage of of
of the of uh the total kind of financial
aid that's that
that various students get does the do
the scholarships represent
how important is it uh to them not to
lose that
versus the importance of attracting
of attracting uh people to stay to stay
in new hampshire and work here and i'm
i'm just wondering if it would make
sense
to take a little more time to study that
um before we make this decision
i if i may i just would like to uh add
it because i i'm the one that sees the
numbers
the number of awards that um are
provided i have to say that
the those scholarships are very
important to new hampshire students
and um i mean i have a number that um
the latest numbers for the endowment
program
just gave out 2192 awards
um in their range between 1 000 and um
thirty six thousand was one school that
provided thirty six thousand to one
student
and again it's because they have to um
they have to disperse that
four percent that they're required it's
a four percent minimum they have to
disperse from
four percent of the total balance so um
some of the scholarships are
really um key to some of some of the
students
and the annual award the annual
allocation program
that that has been difficult to fund
just because of that limitation
it always received 20 of the funding so
the
award amount was has been 800 for
for several years just because of that
and so
the the because there wasn't enough fun
then it was set in the rules
it was 80 20. uh but with the change
that was made this year
um again the legibility criteria was
expanded and some more awards
and more money was provided so in um in
there were um
about 4 500 awards provided to part-time
and
in full-time students and again that one
it was just
a minimum of 800 and then this current
year
and in fiscal year 21
we we we were able to provide a thousand
dollar awards
um i don't have the data on those
numbers i don't have we will
probably have some information by the
end of the year by
probably may make time frame
representative lynn if i understand what
you're saying
is that um this
529 commission i assume
would be the ones to study this
issue or is i don't
you're sort of ahead or is there some
other higher education commission
that we would uh task
because i don't necessarily think
because this money is all outside the
budget
if i'm not mistaken except for
the governor's scholarship program
that's in the budget
but all of this other stuff is outside
the budget
so it could be brought back
next year to um
to take care of and it would simply be
a delay of a year in how
this is managed i don't know uh
james if do you want to comment on that
or or do you think there's
you know we ought to go ahead i don't
know i know i know you don't care
all right so thanks
thank you and if i could if i could well
i'm sorry you know what if i could just
say i
i don't i i don't really i hadn't
thought
you're you're ahead of me uh
representative umberger i hadn't really
thought on
who would do the study and i'm not sure
i really would
care um maybe it's you know maybe
maybe the governor's office should just
do that um and provide some further
information or maybe it should be the
529 commission or
um i i don't really have a preference on
that i'm just sort of thinking maybe
more information would be better
thank you so
uh madam chair to answer your question
you're right i can't say whether i think
we should go forward or not
within a year you know what i can say
i think to kind of go along with the
treasurer's comments
about the scholarships are certainly
important to
students um you know eight hundred
dollars isn't
it doesn't sound like a lot but i'm sure
it's helpful for those that get it
the other side of the policy
consideration is if you look at
you know recent graduates their job
choices where they locate
you ask them what the most important
thing that they find student debt is the
top of the list
every single time you know they need
they're burdened by student debt
need to go to a job market that can pay
them you know in a way that they can
retire student debt
because the debt level is the same
whether you graduate from college a
dollar is a dollar
and if new hampshire's labor market
wages are lower it's hard to compete
today with massachusetts or new york
where you make
more dollars and your debt's the same so
you can pay it off so
debt is very important it's one of the
top things they mentioned along with
affordable housing um
students or i should say students
employees also say that
study has shown a dollar of student loan
forgiveness is worth a lot more in
people's minds than a dollar of extra
pay so you get you get a lot of extra
bang for your buck
so i think scholarships are obviously
very important for people
that forgiveness is very important for
folks
um as well so i just wanted to
put that matthew did you want to comment
on this or did you want to comment on
something else
uh on this topic uh sherwood if i if i
may
um just to say that i appreciate
representative lin's comments on you
know making sure we get this
right but what i would say is that this
issue has had a lot of conversation over
the past couple of years
expanding back to the last budget uh and
then subsequent conversations
uh in 2020 so what we've brought forward
i feel is a good compromise from where
the governor started his first budget
and through the legislative process and
ongoing conversations
you know we've come to a spot that
addresses challenges that we
we don't need to study because we know
they exist today the first and foremost
being workforce in critical sectors
uh like healthcare um so you know i
think the legislature
um you know is in a good position to to
you know make this decision to endorse
student debt relief for these
critical sectors and
that's something that i don't know we
need or would glean any more information
from a study commission because i think
we all have experienced that
issue acutely during this pandemic
and trying to james point uh give people
that incentive that
is meaningful as tangible and someone
that has
student loans i'm currently paying off
myself
a program like this would certainly come
into the equation of where would i want
to work after college right do i want to
maybe go make a few more dollars in
boston
or do i want to stay here in new
hampshire
with this type of an incentive program
if i worked in one of those eligible
fields
that would be a tangible benefit that
massachusetts or any other state
currently doesn't offer so there is a
compelling interest for new hampshire to
lead on that
point and do it now
thank you uh rep
represent uh represent just a moment
if i could uh mickey how do how do we
know
it can the uh people that are attending
can they raise their hand if they want
to speak because i
i know of at least two people that have
contacted me
that want to speak uh yes they they can
and if you'd like me to bring them in i
can
if you're ready no yeah until i see
their hand raised
before you see it then let's um we'll
continue here i don't
i don't see any hands raised but okay
representative i do there is one
representative
i've got uh mr ed mckay and tom cronin
from the university system with their
hands raised now
okay um let's
let's do representative porter you have
a question
i do madam chair thank you um
i think i'd like to get this clear in my
head because i might be misunderstanding
we had a very powerful presentation last
week from the university system and the
community college system about the
changing demographics and the
struggle to find students to attend the
various institutions and the competition
between
institutions for those students
will this change as proposed
reduce the amount of financial
incentives
that our local universities
and community colleges have
to attract students to come to their
institutions
will the pool of money that they have be
reduced
will it be increased so they can in
in encourage more people to come or will
it stay the same
thank you so this
proposal relative to the university
endowments will continue to put
more money in than currently exists
today
so endowments obviously have a return on
investment
the money we've put in over the past two
decades
has been there has increased has grown
and they're paying scholarships on it
the state through this program will
continue to make
additional investments in those
endowments
they will continue to have interests
they will continue to pay scholarships
even if we put proportionally less money
to them there still is an existing
and ongoing benefit to those endowments
that will continue to increase the
availability of those schools
to pay additional scholarships to
students
thank you mickey maybe you could bring
up mr mckay first
and then um
mr cronin from the university
good morning mr mckay i'm happy to see
that you were
able to uh figure out how to
get into our meeting we are all
zoom challenged so don't don't feel like
uh don't feel like you're alone we did
send
out your um written testimony
to uh all of the committee so
if and i know that you've heard all of
the comments that have been uh
going around and round and round on this
and so i just like to um
kind of get a
summary or maybe uh you know of where
you
stand on this uh this whole
issue uh and it appears that the real
discussion that we've been having is
not on the um the percentages or any of
that
but rather on the workforce
part of this discussion so
i would appreciate if you could um
give us some thoughts on that thank you
uh
thank you chairman chairman hamburger
and members of
the division too thank you for the
opportunity and i
uh to speak to you today and also i
hopefully in the written testimony
i walk through a number of the issues
that have been discussed here
um but let me then hit the highlights if
you will
and ask that the committee consider
honoring the commitment when the 529
plan was established
and that is to ensure that all the fees
received are provide scholarships for
the benefits of the residents of the
state
pursuing programs to study at eligible
institutions within the state
and i want to follow up on the march 8th
commission meeting which i did observe
and
in that meeting as monica stated near
the end of that meeting
the commission reiterated its commitment
to reducing
the proportion of the incoming fees
going to endowments to 30 percent
that was a position the commission had
taken last year due the inability to get
gel car approval
and went to the governor's executive
order process but i think it is fair to
say
that that's the consensus on the part of
the
commission and that's the intent going
forward so 70 percent of the incoming
fees
under the commission's perspective and i
understand they need to jail car
approval for this
this change would be to have the fees
go to either the annual award or the
governor's scholarship program
as stated previously the annual award is
particularly effective
for serving adult learners and others
coming
directly from school but particularly
adult learners who are key to meeting
our workforce needs
as as many of you know i've worked a
long time on workforce issues with 65 by
25 and so forth
and the biggest opportunity for the
state of new hampshire is to look at
those 140 000
adults in the state who have some
college but have not completed
a degree or a high value credential and
by providing the aid through the
annual award we're particularly focusing
on that population
the governor's scholarship program has
been exclusively funded
from general fund support to date it's a
non-lapsing appropriation
and by um and under the modeling that
i've done
and others with spreadsheet that program
the governor's scholarship program plus
the annual awards plus the 30
allocation to the endowment program is
fully sustainable
from fee incoming 529 fees and there
will be no
future general fund appropriation needed
to support
the governor's scholarship or any other
element and why is that important
because that provides long-term
assurance to the families in new
hampshire
they will have access to student
financial aid for students
in state and to go back to
representative porter's question and
others
one of the key issues for us now as we
face these demographic headwinds
is providing insurance to new hampshire
families that aid will be there
so they can stay in state right now
we're losing almost half our students
pursuing
pursuing two or four year degrees going
out of state
it's critically important that we
provide that assurance of these families
with financial need that if you stay in
state you can not only enroll in state
but you can accelerate your degree in
the sense of going full-time you have
more
aid and again by my own modeling
i believe the uh the current one
thousand dollar annual award could be
increased to fifteen hundred so i walked
through in the written testimony the
the total uh fee amount coming in 17 to
18 million
deducting at 30 for the endowment
program you take off the audit and other
required fees you have
roughly give or take 12 million dollars
available for the annual for the
uh annual award program in the
governor's scholarship program
again those are fully funded uh in
for the foreseeable future uh from those
two sources
and let me speak again also to the value
of the
endowment program as monica has
correctly stated there's a minimum of
four percent that has to be paid out
each year and that that amount is
growing
substantially each year but not only
that there's not a dime of
administrative costs that can be
assessed against those endowments
so that's been a critical feature in the
creation of programs such as the granite
guarantee knowing there was a governor's
scholarship program annual war
program and the endowment which provides
the flexibility for financial aid
officers to package a program such that
you can then make the offer of the
granite guarantee
and essentially making new hampshire
residents
who are pedal eligible be able to go to
one of the
residential campuses and universities
free tuition-free
so again there's major improvements here
and i think
and the future is is tremendous for
these programs but i also
think it's important to address the
other aspects of what is
proposed by the diversion of the 60 fees
um we've had a lot of discussion james
and i and others have talked and we've
testified
previously on is this the best use of
those fees let me suggest that
with the initial cares act which was
approved last march
for the first time businesses can deduct
up to five thousand two hundred and
fifty dollars
a year for payments to employees to
reduce their student debt their debt is
immediately reduced by the 5
250 now that was only a one-year
provision but in the second iteration of
the cares act
approved by congress in december they
put a five-year window on it
so this is good for five years and
there's very very strong bipartisan
support
so i think that program exists long term
so every business that wants to help pay
down student debt
has a deduction which again is also
other come to me i think that's going to
be tax free to the
the employee receiving that payment to
pay down the principal on the student
debt
uh so that's another benefit of that now
if
the trouble with for and again james
understands this and he's been very
honest and candid about
how to present the trouble of forgivable
loans to millennials
they say wait a minute it's you're
substituting one loan for another
and it doesn't my debt's not reduced for
five years but
millennials say five years that's a
lifetime i mean you know what what
happens do i
get married have a kid i do something
else so forgivable loans are not an
attractive
option generally for millennials or
young young people
it does not enable them to reduce their
aggregate debt
they delay household there's no
acceleration of household formation
which
basically if there's a way to pay down
the debt more quickly then that's much
more attractive to millennials
so let me suggest an alternative that
i've suggested before
if there's an interest on the pardon
businesses in new hampshire or
industries identified by the governor's
office or others that
really are critical to this thing then
why not simply
provide a tax credit against the
business profits tax or the business
enterprise tax for the amount
over 5250 which is already a tax
deduction
for example if i'm one of these army
companies and i wanna
pay down ten thousand dollars and that
would be immediately off the student's
debt
then i could take the five thousand two
hundred fifty dollar
federal deduction in addition take a tax
credit of four thousand seven hundred
and fifty dollars
you talk about big bang for your buck
and it will only go to the companies
that have skin in the game that are
partnering with the state
and are aggressive in saying we want to
help you attract
and retain young employee young
professionals to this state
so i think there are more cost-effective
more efficient
ways to achieve the goal
of the governor's office and others
while also maintaining
that revenue stream for new hampshire
families
in terms of being able to provide
support for new hampshire students going
students with financially going to
college in new hampshire
where they are far more likely to secure
a workplace
internship or practicum experience and
then stay work and play
in new hampshire i apologize for going
on
representative bombardo i have some real
energy
and interest
my question to you is that um
some of this loan forgiveness was going
to
um people that were working for the
state
yes and um so my if i could
i i in the the written testimony i
suggest that the governor's office had
proposed
in the upcoming biennium three million a
year to support the governor's
scholarship program again that's not
necessary
under the plan that would retain all the
529 fees within the 529 commission
so repurpose the six million dollars and
provide it to the state loan repayment
plan
that's administered by hhs for those
health centers and other
not-for-profit industries
does anyone know if that 6 million is
still in there or if it's gone
don't all speak at once if i may madam
chair um the six million is yes so the
governor's scholarship program
um we're being we're budgeting three
million each year so that's the six
million dollars that um
um mr mckay is referring to and and that
is in treasury's budget
my my understanding however is uh
division one has moved to
recommend reducing that that
appropriation essentially to nothing
so i just wanted to just keep us in the
loop with what division one
is recommending for that program that
was my
understanding as well so good thought
but
yeah i wasn't aware of that thank you
hey um i see catherine provencher is
here
are you going to speak for the
university side
or is don
good still morning good morning chair
members of the committee
um i'll take this one i really think um
much has been already said so i just
wanted to reiterate a couple of points
again um catherine provencher chief
administrative officer
university system um the
i i would like to point out that um the
two programs
differ i'm not taking a position on the
value of either program but one program
is workforce business and economic
development
and one program is uh
scholarship dollars for the various
needy
i mean the the neediest students when
we're talking about an estimated family
contribution of zero
these are our neediest new hampshire
students
the the other point i wanted to
reiterate i attended my
first unique commission meeting a week
ago today
since i had been state treasurer and i
do want to
reiterate the point that monica made
that the committee the commission
made two votes one
if the program is to move forward as
written in house bill two
the commission would seek to have
flexibility
with that twenty percent twenty 20
there's a recognition on the part of the
unique commission
that we need to get dollars into
students hands
now and so the commission may
may um seek to have
a hundred percent of the 40 go directly
to
to annual scholarships the second part
of the motion was
should this legislation
not proceed as written in house bill 2
the commission would immediately move to
jailcar to have the
split between annual scholarships
and an endowment portion moved to
70 direct 30 endowment
as is currently the case for this
one year temporary allocation um
that that's that's about it for me again
we're not taking a position on the
worthy
the worthiness of either program i think
they're both
they both have could
have we don't know but could have
really high impact on the state
but um the the best of both worlds of
of course would be able to do both
so so i'm going to leave it at that and
i'm happy to take any questions i did
want to
um you probably already know this and i
think mr mckay mentioned this
the the it's 18 and a half
million dollars a year that's coming in
through these fidelity assessments
so it's it's a big
chunk of of dollars coming in
and so 60 going to
the um the debt relief program
would be about 10.8 million dollars a
year
going to the debt relief and then the 40
would be 7.2 million combined
going to to the scholarships so
it is a um and those i said the
estimates are it's about 18 and a half
million
almost for fiscal years 21 22 and 23.
i used 18 million because you know we
have to pay for an
audit and there is some administrative
costs but that that's just an
estimate madam chair
kathy could i maybe add just two quick
items
and again i apologize if mr mckay didn't
mention these uh and madame treasurer i
think you you would mention that 10
colleges and universities are
participating in the program
i'm just curious if you were actually
combining usnh and ccsnh sort of as
as one entity there uh it was my
understanding that essentially every
college and university in the state
is eligible to participate
if i can hop in monica just to clarify i
think that's what you meant is there's
five uh
private institutions plus the 11
institutions in the community college
university so a total of 16
current participants that is correct we
combine them yes
great thank you um and then just to
maybe one of the questions that was sort
of being asked and i think kathy just
this morning sent over the fiscal now
note for the university system but in
terms of the endowment and again mr
mckay definitely spoke to this but
our estimate is through the diversion
if the commission doesn't change the
allocations which there are they are
talking about doing
but even if you kept it at 80 20 um
that means about 200 000 every single
year
in less money able to come out of the
endowments to scholarships
and that's two thousand dollars in year
one plus two thousand two hundred
thousand more in year two
plus two hundred thousand more in year
three on and on and on so
again the way the endowments work and
they continue to build and make money
over time
as this can as this can this diversion
continues it really does become a very
significant
pot of money that is no longer available
for student loans
or student for student scholarships
uh james did you want to comment on that
or
was it something else yes uh if i could
madam chair i just
you know wanted to also point out i
think in addition to tom's point so
the 200 000 i'm not sure exactly how the
map works i assume that's the four
percent
that four percent of what wouldn't be
going
to endowments in the future it's not
two hundred thousand dollars less than
what is being given out
now it's sort of two hundred thousand
dollars less a year that
might be given out more than what's
going away now so
the trade-off would be keeping it
as it is now or it would go up like
200 000 a year if you don't have that
increase of 200 grand a year
what you gain is 10 million a year
student debt
relief you lose 200 000 a year
in school that's right james just to be
clear though that 200 000 is
just the usnh portion it does not
account for
pretty much a similar 200 000 going
across the rest of the state
uh matt did you have something on this
issue
her lips are moving but no sound
sorry about that can you hear me now
just just clarification that when thomas
and i think james touched on this but
that is not a
real reduction in what we're paying out
it is
the delta between the continual
increases and the continual
disbursements to the fund
which will continue to increase as
opposed to the status quo so just want
to make sure we're talking reductions
they are potential as opposed to uh
actual dollars currently in endowments
which we would see additional
scholarships paid out
that's right that's matt and james have
it right
right but right when we prepare a fiscal
note we have to compare
what the current rule says
compared to what the few the legislation
says so currently you'd have
80 percent going into endowments and
that
over time translates to those dollars
not going to endowments
results in two hundred thousand dollars
less
compounding each year
okay uh represent petrie did you have a
question on this or was it on something
else
well uh thank you madam chair uh i was
just wondering what the total
student debt was in the state of new
hampshire
i'm not sure that anyone has a
clear idea of
how much student debt there is in the
state of new hampshire
okay i think the last statistic i saw
where students that do have debt the
average debt was around thirty seven
thousand dollars in new hampshire
that's a ballpark figure but i think
it's close
thank you see that
uh mick has brought up a couple of
uh people to uh to talk to us
and uh mr williams you were up first i
believe
yes hello uh thank you uh for having me
representative umberger my name is
alfred williams i'm the president at
river valley community college and i'm
represented in the community college
system in new hampshire
one of the reasons why i'm here today is
that i have a extensive background in
financial aid and
i started in higher education when i was
in law school as a graduate assistant in
financial aid and
in all my years in higher education i
have either directly supervised or ran a
financial aid office
um we're not taking a position on the
legislation but i just wanted to
point out some of the ways that the
scholarship program impacts community
college students
our students uh the
the the it seems like it may be small
amounts but those small amounts have a
significant impact on our students a
thousand dollar award
uh 1500 award can mean the difference
between taking
a class uh taking an additional class
finishing as quickly as possible
and our students stay in new hampshire
they uh
that you know our graduates all take
jobs for the for the most part the
majority of them in new hampshire
and we can see that the impact
particularly of the unique annual funds
which is
geared towards full pell students has a
real impact on changing
getting people out of poverty if you
look at river valley community college
and white mountains community college
they have the highest some of the
highest rates of income jumps
of any community colleges in the country
uh where students
jump from the lowest fifth of income to
the three-fifths of income within five
years of graduation
and some of that is a direct result of
the funding that goes to those full pell
students to get them through as quick as
possible and get them into the job
job force so we can see that the the
scholarships have a real impact on our
students
a real impact on their ability to get
into the workforce and uh and and work
and live in new hampshire
so if i'm hearing oh you're not take
you're not taking a position
okay thank you is there anybody out
there that's taking a position
[Music]
sorry uh is it scary
is it deborah scary it is yes thank you
um yes i'm debbie scary and i serve as
the president of
excuse me you need to university council
you need to speak up or move closer to
your microphone
try this see if that helps is that a
little bit better
yeah sorry about that um
many of you probably are familiar with
the nhcuc but if you aren't i'll just
say it's
a non-profit consortium of the public
and private institutions
here in new hampshire um and these
institutions are really recognized
and highly regarded for their
outstanding research
teaching community service activities
and they serve certainly as major active
uh major centers of activity that are
vital to the economic development of the
community
and to our state and i also serve
as the newly elected chairperson of the
new hampshire college tuition savings
plan which we'll refer to
for ease purposes as unique today
many people have made um i think some of
the um
most important salient points already
there's a couple i just like to really
reiterate um and i guess the most
important one to me is really that the
monthly
the fees the annual fees generated by
the plan
are used and have been used exclusively
to since its inception
very successfully to provide
scholarships to our neediest new
hampshire students
and their families attending new
hampshire schools so again it's a new
hampshire program very
through and through um i also want to
make sure that we've been clear about
the extensive
reach that this particular program has
and so since its inception
the 529 commission or the unique
commission has awarded more than 72
000 scholarships again to
to our neediest new hampshire students
helping the students get an education
stay and succeed right here in new
hampshire
those two are very important things we
talked a little bit
um treasurer mazzapelli did a great job
sort of talking about what
uh motions were made at our meeting just
a week ago
i think it's really important to
reiterate a couple of things from there
that when we talked about making uh the
70 30
uh split um that it had worked well and
that
we would do as a commission
vote to make to make that change
permanent if we were able
to take that opportunity that it is
definitely the
commission's intent to make that
permanent and while there was really
no position taking on the worthiness of
the bill or the proposal
in hb um two we as a commission realize
it could happen
and we want to be sure that people know
um that we
are very flexible um as a commission and
willing to to work with folks
um again you know under this proposal
non-new hampshire students would
not have um necessarily
the same kinds of intentionality around
the focus on new hampshire media
students
there's a lot of unknowns with this
particular proposal as
as folks have stated stated when it was
started it was
considered a pilot and now under this
proposal will be codified really in this
issue
and posed to grow substantially over
time
and certainly while workforce
development is an important
program for new hampshire it should
really not be untaken i don't think at
the expense of scholarship for new
hampshire's neediest students
and the final point i want to make is
that new hampshire's funding for
scholarships
general student scholarships is
extremely low relative to other states
and when you compare new hampshire
expenditures against other states and
territories
over the time we have ranked second from
the bottom
in total dollars spent by the state so
there are
the the challenge here i think is that
this these are there are no
other funds really being committed at
the level that we're talking about here
so we certainly encourage new hampshire
legislators to honor the successful
program
um that unique has had and our
long-standing compact with the families
and students of new hampshire who
directly benefit from these scholarships
thank you thank you deborah
a representative lynn you have a
question
yes thank you madam chair and i i this
is i guess would be directed
to either matt or james am i
understanding
correctly that under the under the loan
forgiveness program
there would not be a requirement that in
order for a person to be
to be eligible for that the person had
to have attended
college in new hampshire and and i guess
if and if that's true
then i guess my only question would be
you know
we we do do that for the for the
scholarship program we say it only
applies if you're going to school in new
hampshire
and you know i that's a choice
presumably to encourage
people to go to school in new hampshire
which is i'm not
you know that i'm not saying that's a
bad thing i'm just
i'm just making that observation and so
if we do that
for the scholarship program would it
make sense to
put that as a requirement on the loan
forgiveness program that we want you to
stay in new hampshire and
if you know if you've gone to school in
new hampshire maybe there's a better
chance you're going to stay in new
hampshire and so this will be just sort
of a further incentive
i i don't know the answer to that but i
just asked the question
no and that's a very fair question
representative um
you're correct that the legislation does
not require them to have
attended a new hampshire institution but
they would need to be a new hampshire
resident
working for a new hampshire company
that the idea there is to cast the
broadest net possible to address the
workforce
sectors that we're trying to again
incentivize people to continue to live
and work in new hampshire
if the committee wanted to further
restrict that to
new hampshire graduates that live in new
hampshire that work in new hampshire
the the committee could take that action
but again it just restricts
that pool and also limits the
possibility for this proposal to attract
new workforce to new hampshire um and
that's the consideration that we just
would need to balance
you representative heath
you have a question yes thank you um and
this question
um is for either deb scary and it's nice
to see your deb
or um catherine provencher who actually
weren't you one of the architects of of
the unique program but my real question
is
what would really this program benefits
um all our colleges are all our new
hampshire colleges and universities
be they public or private what will be
the overall
impact to our institutions if
the if this program were to be changed
as such the recommendation is
thank you uh mary i can i can start and
kathy please
build on here i think you know we've
we've just stated
it's um it's a huge uh amount 60
off the top um that would not be going
to scholarships i guess that's the
the piece that's you know important um
and the fact number two is that there
are no other resources that we really
have in new hampshire
that would be able to really make up for
this is you know this is what we point
to
when we talk about um aid to students at
the state level
so i think you know it would be profound
thanks
thank you representative heath no i was
not the architect of this program
that goes back to mike about
and governor shaheen oh okay
um i want to reiterate
what matt and james have said earlier
if this legislation passes as is
under current rule there will be no
change in direct scholarships
and the endowment scholarships that are
paid out right now will continue
to be paid out at the same
level they are right now
it you know it would the way the
endowment works is
monica mentioned um i think the total is
137 138 million across
the state and all the in all the
colleges and universities
the university systems portion of that
is 67 million dollars
as of last june 30. the way in and down
and this is like most endowments the way
this works is we take the
average balance over the market value
over the last 12 quarters you apply
four percent to that and it will pay out
at that rate and those scholarships go
to the neediest new hampshire students
so without the endowment growing further
those amounts will still continue to pay
out now over time
it won't keep up with inflation but if
you had a portion of it going to
two endowments it will keep up with
inflation but again
the the endowment won't grow so more
scholarships won't be available in the
future
now that's again that's it existing rule
as is with this 80 20 split
the answer changes if in fact
the rule were changed as voted by the
commission to go
70 percent for
annual scholarships and 30 for endowment
to keep up with inflation
right seven right now 20 percent of 18
million dollars
is 2.6 million 3.6 million dollars
so that is about the amount that's being
paid out in
annual direct scholarships
per year if that number changed to 70
percent of the 18 million dollars
now we're paying out 12.6 million
dollars a year
in direct scholarships am i con
i'm probably confusing the issue it's
already so confusing
uh no actually surprisingly it makes
sense to me
[Laughter]
sorry representative lynn you have a
question
oh no i'm sorry i don't know how my hand
got up i do not have a question thank
you
okay i think maybe you didn't put it
down
uh all right
okay so um
i think we all have a lot of thinking to
do on this i
really really appreciate
everyone's comments today and
it certainly has helped me
in understanding this
entire proposal as i read it
every you know every time i read it i
came up with different thoughts but i
think i have
now at least a clear understanding of
what is in hb2
and obviously we've got
um i we have
i think i'm also hearing that we don't
want to put the percentage in
legislation
but rather what we want to do is
give the unique program the ability to
change that
in rules and i don't know if that's the
way the legislation is right now or
it's some something else uh but
you don't want it to be in legislation i
i got that
totally and i can i can
we can make sure that happens if um
if it isn't that way right now and
um the other thing is
as i said um we're going to have to
um the workforce issue
is obviously of concern
and
representative lynn i think
i'm not sure that the workforce
issue has been um
what do i want to say i think it's a
good idea
to highlight particular
industries where we are really
suffering from not
having sufficient people to be there but
on the other hand uh mr mckay has said
that um you know the businesses
uh can already get a
tax deduction for
paying that so these are just some of
the issues that
um we're gonna have to
um to work out and obviously
we're not going to do it today but
um we are going to have to do it soon
so put your thinking caps on and
um because if we need to
redo legislation uh
we've got to give mickey some kind of
thought about
about where we're going uh because you
can't
you know you can't just say well mickey
make this up
uh so i although i'm sure he could do a
very good job
with it but uh but we do need to uh to
give him some
some ideas as to where we are
uh that we can get some kind of
consensus on so
um i think
that we will recess until
one o'clock when we're going to tackle
another issue that
obviously will be a problem
and maybe or maybe not and that's
dealing with
a new commission of
looking at um the uh
lorry list problem if that's the right
term
so that'll be that'll be another another
fun
afternoon so uh we'll see you all
at um 1
have a good lunch